the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so let me remind you yesterday we've
defined and started to compute line
integrals for work of a vector field
along a curve okay so we have a curve in
the plane see we have a vector field F
that gives us a vector at every point
and we want to find the work done along
the curve so that's the line integral
along c of f dot dr are not
geometrically line integral along c of F
dot T DS where T is the unit tangent
vector and D s is the arc length element
or in coordinates that's the integral of
M DX plus n dy where m and n are the
components of a vector field okay so
let's do an example that will just
summarize what we did yesterday and then
we'll move on to interesting
observations about this mix so here's an
example we'll we're going to look at now
let's say I give you the vector field
why I plus XJ so it's not completely
obvious what it looks like but here's a
computer plot of that vector field so
that tells you a bit what it does point
in all sorts of directions and let's say
we want to find the work done by this
vector field if I move along this closed
curve I start at the origin but I moved
along the x axis to 1 then I move along
the unit circle to the diagonal and then
I move back to the origin in a straight
line
okay so C consists of three parts so
that you enclose a sector of a unit disk
corresponding to angles between 0 and 45
degrees so to compute this line integral
well what we have to do is we have to
set up three different integrals and add
them together
okay so we need to set up the integral
of Y DX plus X dy for each of these
piece each of these pieces so let's do
the first one on the x-axis well one way
to parameterize that is to just use the
X variable and say that because we are
on V so so we are going from the origin
to one zero well we know we're on the
x-axis so that Y there is actually just
zero and the variable will be x from
zero to one if you prefer you can
parameterize things say x equals T for T
from zero to 1 and y equals zero what
doesn't change is Y is 0 and therefore
dy is also zero so in fact we are
integrating Y DX plus X dy but that
becomes well zero DX plus zero and
that's just going to give you zero okay
so that the line integral here is very
easy to compute of course you can also
do it geometrically because
geometrically you can see on the picture
along the x-axis the vector field is
pointing vertically right if I'm on the
x axis my vector field is actually in
the Y direction so it's perpendicular to
my curve so the work done is going to be
zero F dot T will be zero
so after T zero so the integral is zero
okay any questions about this first part
of the calculation nope it's okay okay
let's move on to more interesting part
of it let's do the second part which is
a portion of a unit circle okay so we I
should have drawn my picture and so now
we are moving on this part of the curve
that's c2 and of course we have to
choose how to express x and y in terms
of a single variable well most likely
when you're moving on a circle you're
going to use the angle along the circle
to tell you where you are okay so we are
going to use the angle theta as
parameter and we'll say well we're on
the unit circle so X is cosine theta and
Y is sine theta what's the range of
theta theta goes from zero to PI over
four okay so whenever I see DX I will
replace it by well the derivative of
cosine is negative sine so minus sine
theta D theta and dy the derivative of
sine is cosine so it will become cosine
theta D theta okay so I'm computing the
integral of Y DX plus X dy that means
I'll be actually computing the integral
of Y is sine theta DX that's negative
sine theta D theta plus X cosine dy is
cosine theta D theta from zero to PI
over four okay so that's integral from
zero to PI over four of cosine square
minus sine Square and if you know your
trig then you should recognize this as
cosine of two theta okay so that will
integrate to one half of sine two theta
from zero to PI over 2 PI over four
sorry and sine PI over two is one so you
will get one half any questions about
this one nope
okay then let's do the third one so the
third guy is when we come back to the
origin along the diagonal okay so we go
in a straight line from this point
where's this point well this point is 1
over root 2 1 over root 2 and we go back
to the origin ok so we need to figure
out a way to express x and y in terms of
the same parameter so one way which is
very natural would be to just say well
let's say we move from here to here over
time and you know at time 0 we're here
at time 1 we're here we know how to
parameterize this line so what we could
do is say let's parameterize this line
so we start at 1 over root 2 and we go
down by 1 over 2 in time 1 and same with
Y that's actually perfectly fine but
that's unnecessarily complicated ok why
is it complicated because we'll get you
know all of these expressions would be
easier to actually just look at motion
in this direction and then say well if
we have a certain work if we move from
here to here then the work done moving
from here to here is just going to be
the opposite okay so in fact we can do
slightly better by just saying well
we'll take x equals T y equals T T from
0 to 1 over 2 and take well
that gives that gives us what I will
call - C 3 which means C 3 backwards and
then we can say the integral for work on
- C 3 is the opposite of the work along
C 3
oh you know if you're comfortable with
integration where variables go down then
you could also say that interest goes
from 1 over square root of 2 down to 0
and you know when you set up your
integral it will go from 1 over 2 to 0
and of course that would be the negative
of a 1 from 0 to 1 over root 2 so it's
the same thing okay so if we do it with
this parameterization
we'll get that well of course
DX is DT dy is DT so the integral along
- C 3 of Y DX plus X dy is just the
integral from 0 to 1 over 2 of T DT plus
T DT sorry I'm messing up my blackboard
ok which is going to be well the
integral of 2t DT which is T squared
between these bounds which is 1/2 that's
the integral along - if we along the
reversed path and if I want if I want to
do it along c3 instead then I just take
the negative okay or if you prefer you
could have done it directly with
integral from 1 over 2 to 0 which gives
you immediately the negative 1/2 okay so
at the end we get that the total work
was the sum of three line integrals I'm
not fighting FDR just to save space
that's zero plus 1/2 minus 1/2 and that
comes out to zero so a lot of
calculations for nothing
ok so that should give you a good
overview of you know various ways to
compute line integrals any questions
about all that no ok so next let me tell
you about how to avoid computing line
integrals well one is easy
don't take this class but let's not
so here's another way not to do it okay
so let's look a little bit about one
kind of vector field that actually we've
encountered a few weeks ago without
saying it so we said when we have a
function of two variables we have a
gradient vector well at the time it was
just a vector but that vector depended
on x and y so in fact it's a vector
field okay
so here's an interesting special case
say that F our vector field is actually
the gradient of some function so it's a
gradient field and so f is a function of
two variables x and y and that's called
the potential for the vector field the
reason is of course on physics you know
in physics you call potential well
electrical potential or gravitational
potential the potential energy this
function of position that stores that
tells you how much actually energy is
stored somehow by the force field and
its gradient gives you the force
actually not quite if you're a physicist
then the force will be negative the
gradient so that means that physicists
potentials are the opposite of the
mathematicians potential okay so let's
just here to confuse you it doesn't
really matter on button so to make
things simpler we are using this
convention and you know you just put a
minus sign if you're doing physics so
then I claim we can simplify the
evaluation of the line integral for work
okay so perhaps you've seen in physics
the work done by say the electrical
force is actually given by the change in
value of a potential from the starting
point to the ending point same for
gravitational force so these are special
cases of what's called the fundamental
theorem of calculus for line integrals
so the fundamental theorem of calculus
not for line integrals tells you if you
integrate a derivative then you get back
the function and here it's the same
thing in multivariable calculus it tells
you if you take the line integral of the
gradient of a function what you get back
is the function
okay so fundamental theorem of calculus
for line integrals says following thing
it says if you integrate a vector field
that's the gradient of a function along
a curve let's say that you have a curve
that goes from some starting point p 0
to some ending point P 1 then all you
will get is the value of F at P 1 minus
the value of F at P 0 ok so that's a
pretty nifty formula but it only works
if the field that you're integrating is
a gradient you know it's a gradient and
you know the function little F I mean we
can't put just any vector field in here
we have to put the gradient of F so
actually on Tuesday we'll see how to
decide whether a vector field is a
gradient or not and if it is a gradient
how to find the potential function so
we'll cover that but for now we're going
to try to figure out a bit you know more
about this what it says what it means
physically how to think about it
geometrically and so on
so maybe I should say you know if you
try to avoid wasting coordinates because
that's also useful way to think about it
if I give you the line integral along c
so the gradient field the components are
F sub X and F sub y so it means I'm
actually integrating F sub X DX plus F
sub y dy or if you prefer that's the
same thing as actually integrating DF so
I'm integrating the differential of a
function f well then that's the change
in F and of course if you write it you
know in this form then probably it's
quite obvious to you that this should be
true I mean in this form actually it's
the same statement as in single variable
calculus ok and actually that's how we
prove a theorem so let's prove this
theorem how do we prove it
well let's say I give you a curve and I
ask you to compute this integral how
will you do that well the way you
compute the integral actually is by
choosing a parameter and expressing
everything in terms of that parameter so
we'll set well so we know it's f sub X
DX plus F sub y dy and we'll want to
parameterize C in the form x equals x of
T y equals y of T so if we do that then
DX becomes X prime of T DT dy becomes Y
prime of T DT
so we know X is X of T that tells us DX
is X prime of T DT y is y of T gives us
dy is y prime of T DT so now what we are
integrating actually is becomes the
integral of F sub x times DX DT plus F
sub y times dy DT times DT okay but now
here I recognize a familiar guy I've
seen this one before in the chain rule
okay this guy by the chain rule is the
rate of change of F if I take X and Y to
be functions of T and I plug those into
F so in fact what I'm integrating is DF
DT when I think of f as a function of T
by just you know plugging X and y as
functions of T DT and so maybe actually
if you now say you know I have some
times T goes from some initial time
let's say t0 to t1
and now by the usual fundamental theorem
of calculus I know that this will be
just the change in the value of F
between T 0 and T 1
okay
so integral from T 0 to t 1 of DF DT VT
well that becomes f between T 0 and T 1
F of what we just have to be a little
bit careful here well it's not quite F
of T its F seen as a function of T by
putting X of T and Y of T into it so let
me write that down carefully what I'm
integrating to is f of X of T and Y of T
right does that sound fair yeah okay and
so when I plug in T 1 I get the point
where I am at time T 1 that's the end
point of my curve when I plug T 0 I will
get the starting point of my curve p0
and that's the end of the proof wasn't
that hard
see
okay so let's see an example well let's
look at that example again okay so we
have this curve we had this vector field
could it be that by accident that vector
field was a gradient field so remember
our vector field was Y comma X can we
think of a function whose derivative
respect to X is y and derivative with
respect to Y is X ya x times y sounds
like a good candidate well f of X Y is X
Y okay so that means that the line
integrals that we computed along these
things can be just evaluated from just
finding out with values of F at the
endpoint so here's version two of my
plot where I've added the contour plot
of a function X Y on top of the vector
field actually see how you know the
vector field is still pointing
perpendicular to the level curves that
we have seen just to know remind you and
so now when we move well the origin is
unavailable curve F equals zero and when
we start going along c1 we stay on F
equals zero so there's no work where
potential doesn't change valency to the
potential increases from zero to one
half the work is one-half and then on c3
we go back down from one half to zero
the work is negative one half see that
was much easier than computing
so for example the integral along c2 is
actually just so c2 goes from 1 0 to 1
over root 2 1 over 2 so that's 1/2 minus
0 and that's 1/2 okay because c2 was
going here
and at this point F is 0 at that point
1/2 is 1/2 and similarly for the others
and of course when you sum you get 0
because the total change in F when you
know you go from here to here to here to
here
eventually you're back at the same place
so F hasn't changed okay so that's a
neat trick and it's important
conceptually because a lot of forces are
gradients of potentials I mean namely
gravitational force electric force the
problem is not every vector field is a
gradient a lot of vector fields are not
gradients for example magnetic fields
certainly are not gradients so
a big warning everything today only
applies if F is a gradient field
okay it's not true otherwise
okay still let's see what are the
consequences of a fundamental theorem so
just to put one more time this
disclaimer if F is a gradient field then
what do we have
well there's various nice features of
work done by gradient fields that are
not true for other vector fields so one
of them is this property of path
independence okay so the claim is if I
have a line integral to compute then it
doesn't matter which path I take as long
as it goes from point A to point B it
just depends on the point where I start
the point where I end and that's
certainly false in general but for a
gradient field it works ok so if I have
a point P 0 a point P 1 and I have two
different paths that go there say C 1
and C 2 so they go from the same point
to the same point but in different ways
then in this situation the line integral
along c1 is equal to the line integral
along c2 well actually let me insist
that this is only for gradient fields by
putting gradient F in here just so you
know you don't get tempted to ever use
this for a field that's not a gradient
field
if c1 and c2 have the same start and end
points okay
how do we prove that well it's very easy
we just use the fundamental theorem it
tells us if you compute the line
integral along c1 it's just F at this
point minus F at this point if you do it
for c2 well same so they are same and
for that you don't actually even need to
know what little F is you know in
advance that it's going to be the same
so if I give you a vector field and I
tell you it's the gradient of a
mysterious function but I don't tell you
what the function is and you don't want
to find out you can still use path
independence but only if you know that
it's a gradient
okay okay I guess this one is dead so
that will stay here forever because
nobody's told enough to erase it now
when you come back next year and you
still see that formula you'll see okay
yes but there's no useful information
here I mean that's a good point
okay so what another consequence one it
I mean so if you have a gradient field
it's what's called conservative okay so
what's a conservative field well the
word conservative comes from the idea in
you know in physics is the notion of
conservation of energy it tells you that
you cannot get energy for free out of
your force field so what it means is in
particular you know if you take a closed
trajectory so it reject away that goes
from some point back to the same point
so if C is a closed curve then the work
done along C is zero that's the
definition of what it means to be
conservative if I take any closed curve
the work will always be zero contrary
you know the contrary not conservative
means somewhere there is a curve along
which the work is not zero if you find a
curve where the work is zero that's not
enough to say it's conservative you have
to show that no matter what curve I give
you if it you know it's close curve it
will always be zero
so what that means concretely is you
know if you have a first field that's
conservative then you cannot build
somehow some you know perpetual motion
out of that you can't build something
that will just keep going to power by
that force because that force is
actually not providing any energy after
you've gone you know one loop around
nothing's happened from the point of
view of the energy provided by that
force there's no work coming from the
force while if you have a first field
that's not conservative then you can try
to actually maybe find a loop where the
work will be positive and when you know
that thing will just keep running so
actually if you look at magnetic fields
and transformers or no power adapters
and things like that you precisely you
extract energy from a magnetic field of
course I mean you actually have to take
some power supply to maintain the
magnetic field but so a magnetic field
you could actually try to get energy
from it almost for free a gravitational
field or an electric field you can't
okay so and now why why does that hold
well if I have a gradient field then if
I try to compute this line integral I
know that it will be the value of a
function at the endpoint minus the value
at the starting point but they are the
same so yeah you know the video is the
same
so if I have a gradient field and I do
the line integral then I will get F at
the endpoint minus F at the starting
point but at the same point so that
okay so just to reinforce my warning
that not every field is a gradient field
let's look again at you know our
favorite vector field from yesterday so
our favorite vector field yesterday was
negative Y and X it's a vector field
that just rotates around the origin
counterclockwise well we said if you
take say say you take just the unit
circle for example counterclockwise well
remember we said yesterday that the line
integral of f dot dr maybe I should say
F that TDS now so because the vector
field is tangent to the circle so on the
unit circle F is tangent to the curve
and so f dot t is length F times well
length t but t is a unit vector so it's
length F and the length of F on the unit
circle was just one so that's the
integral of 1 D s so that's just the
length of the circle that's 2 pi and 2pi
is definitely not 0 so this vector field
is not conservative and so now we know
actually it's not the gradient of
anything because if it was if it were a
gradient then it would be conservative
and it's not so tells you you know an
example of a vector field that is not
conservative it's not perfect abandoned
either by the way because see if I go
from here to here
along the upper half circle or under the
lower along the lower half circle in one
case I will get pie in the other case I
will get negative pie I don't get the
same answer and so on and so on a dress
you know fails to have all of these
properties so maybe I will write it down
it's not conservative not path
independent it's not a gradient doesn't
have any of these properties
okay any questions yes how do you
determine whether something is a
gradient of not well that's what we will
see on Tuesday yes
is it possible that it's conservative
and not path independent or vice versa
the answer is no these two properties
are equivalent and we're going to see
that right now at least that's the plan
okay
all right yes
let's see so you said if it's not
perfect pendant then we cannot draw
level curves that are perpendicular to
it at every point I wouldn't necessarily
go that far you might be able to draw
curves that are perpendicular to it but
they want people level curves of a
function for which this is the gradient
I mean you might still have you know if
you take say take this gradient field
and you know scale it but in strange
ways you know multiplied by two in some
places by one in other places by five in
some other places you will get something
that won't be conservative anymore and
it will still be perpendicular to the
curves so it's more subtle than that but
but certainly if it's not conservative
and it's not a gradient and you cannot
do what we said and how to decide
whether it is or not that will be
Tuesday static so for now I just want to
figure out again actually let's now
state all these properties
actually let me first do one minute of
physics so let me just tell you again
you know what's the physics in here so
if the first field is the gradient of a
potential so I'll still keep my plus
sign so maybe I should say this is minus
physics but so the work of F is the
change in value of potential from one
endpoint to the other endpoint and so
you know you might know about verite
oops
gravitational field or electrical field
versus gravitational or electrical
potential and in case you haven't done
you know any 802 yet
electrical potential is also commonly
known as voltage it's the one that makes
it hurt when you stick your fingers into
the socket
don't try okay and so now
conservativeness means no energy can be
extracted for free from the field you
can't just have you know a particle
moving in that field and going on
indefinitely faster and faster or
universe actually friction then you know
keep moving so total energy is conserved
and I guess that's why we call that
conservative okay
okay so let's end with the recap of
various equivalent properties okay so
the first property that I will have our
vector field is that it's conservative
so to say that a vector field is
conservative means that the line
integral is zero along any closed curve
C maybe to clarify sorry along all
closed curves okay every closed curve
budget you know give me any closed curve
I get zero so now I claim this is the
same thing as a second property which is
that the line integral of F is path
independent okay so that means if I have
two paths with the same endpoints then I
will get always the same answer why is
that equivalent well let's say that I'm
path independent if I'm path independent
then if I take a closed curve well it
has the same endpoints as just the curve
that doesn't move at all so path
independence tells me instead of going
all around I could just stay where I am
and when the work would be just zero so
if I'm path independent when I'm
conservative
conversely let's say that I'm just
conservative and I want to check path
independence well so I have two points
and I have two paths between them I want
to show that the work is the same well
how do I do that c1 and c2
well I observe that if I do c1 minus c2
I get a closed path
right if I go first from here to here
and then back along that one I get a
closed path so if I'm conservative I
should get zero but if I get 0 and C 1
minus C 2 it means that we work on C 1
and the work and C 2 are the same C so
it's the same it's just a different way
to think about the situation more things
that are equivalent you have two more
things to say the third one its
equivalent to F being a gradient field
okay so this is equivalent to the third
property F is a gradient field why well
if we know that it's a gradient field
then we've seen that we get these
properties out of a fundamental theorum
question is if I have a conservative of
F independent vector field why is it the
gradient of something okay so this way
is a fundamental theorem that way well
so that actually let me just say that
will be how we find the potential so how
do we find potential well let's say that
I know the value of my potential here
actually I get to choose what it is
remember in physics for potential is
defined up to adding or subtracting a
constant what matters is only the change
in potential so let's say I know my
potential here and they want to know my
potential here what do I do
well I take my favorite particle and I
move it from here to here and I look at
the work done and that tells me how much
potential has changed so that tells me
what the potential should be here and
this does not depend on metals of path
because I've assumed that I'm path
independent so that's what we will do on
Tuesday and let me just state a fourth
property that's the same so all that
stuff is the same as also for if I look
at M DX plus n dy is what's called an
exact differential so what that means an
exact differential means it can be put
in the form D F or some function f and
you know I'm just we're formulating this
thing right because I'm saying just I
can put it in the form f sub X DX plus F
sub y dy which means my vector field was
a gradient field so these things are
believer saying okay so after the
weekend
on Tuesday we'll actually figure out how
to decide whether these things hold or
not and how to find the button